MALE SPEAKER: So welcome back.
We're here at Devoxx with Seth
Ladd, and we're here to talk
about Dart.
So welcome, Seth, to Devoxx.
So this is your first time?
SETH LADD: This is
awesome, yeah.
Thanks for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: Working
well for you?
So you just presented on Dart.
So for those people that have
been living in a cave or under
a rock, can you give us a quick
intro on Dart and how
you call this a new language
for the web.
And it's one thing that I found
interesting is that it's
meant to be enterprising.
So if you can elaborate on that,
I'd love to hear you.
SETH LADD: Well, sure.
The quick version of Dart is--
one of our goals
is to help more
developers come to the Web.
And you've got experienced
developers on platforms like
Java and ActionScript, C++,
C#, that really love the
exciting power of HTML5 in the
modern browser, but would like
to build those apps in a
language and with a set of
tools that feels more familiar,
productive, and
powerful to them.
And so this is certainly what
attracted me as someone who's
come from a Java structured
background and moved to web
programming.
I think it's going to attract
a lot of developers as well.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So the language
part is meant to be
unsurprising, so do you
want to [INAUDIBLE]?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
There's two main core tenets
of the Dart project.
One is that it has to be
recognizable and familiar.
The second is that it must
compile to logical and sane
JavaScript.
But in terms of the language
being familiar, this is not
the opportunity to develop
the world's next
Haskell, for instance.
This is an opportunity for us
to, again, reach out to the
existing legions of developers
on all these different
platforms and say, here's
something that you can jump on
very easily, very quickly, you
feel safe and comfortable
with, and still deploy to the
modern web with HTML5.
And so it was a critical
decision at the early parts of
the project to make something
people can within an hour or
two get up and running.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
As people have understood,
I think, it's not just a
language, it's a platform.
So there's the language, there
are tools around it.
There are testing tools.
Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
SETH LADD: Certainly.
You're absolutely right.
It's much more than just the
language, although that's an
interesting part of it.
But we also have things like
a full editor with code
completion, and refactoring,
and quick fixes, and
debugging, and outlines--
again, trying to make a
familiar tool ability story to
the developers out there.
We also have a package manager,
Pub, so you can
discover and install and
update your third party
dependencies We have a wide
range of libraries that come
built into the SDK.
Certainly, the core libraries
like collections, and dates,
and stuff, but also the
libraries like unittesting,
and mocks, and JSON.
And the list goes on and on.
So all this comes out
of the box as well.
We also have a virtual machine,
so you can run Dart
programs natively on a Dart VM,
which is really important
when you do your development
cycle.
You want to just write some code
and hit Reload, and it
just pops right up
in your web page.
This is the kind of experience
that web developers have had
since the beginning
of time and it's
fantastic for iteration.
And then we also have a compiler
to JavaScript so that
when you're done testing your
app on the virtual machine and
you're ready to ship to
production browsers that don't
Dart VM, you can run Dart
to JS, the compiler to
JavaScript, and then deploy that
out and actually run Dart
across the modern web on
modern web browsers.
MALE SPEAKER: So if we step
back and we look at HTML5,
which is this buzzword which
encompasses a lot of different
technologies and their
frameworks and JavaScript,
such as Backbone.
There are so many of them, and
Angular is probably a very
popular one.
Can you try to position and
explain how they relate to
Dart, to a platform like Dart?
SETH LADD: Well, sure.
I think it's a really good
sign that the JavaScript
community is now embracing these
more structured ways to
build Web apps.
As we need to continue to
innovate and deliver the
really fantastic, high fidelity,
complex, silky
smooth experiences that
users demand,
we need more structure.
I think we need the frameworks
out there.
So that's really cool.
So you mentioned Backbone.
Backbone is a simple
way to construct
your models and views.
Angular puts a lot of the data
binding into your actual HTML,
which is really cool.
But ultimately, at the end of
the day, they're still running
on top of JavaScript,
which for a ton
of people is fantastic.
But for developers familiar in
other languages, we want to
give them a fantastic web
development experience.
And so we talked about
the language and
libraries and tools.
But we're also building to help
them actually use it to
build modern Web apps.
We're building out
Web components--
capabilities.
And this gives you the two
way data binding, the
encapsulation of styles,
behavior, and structure, the
ability for you to extend
HTML classes.
Like, you can extend button
and create fancy button,
create your own custom
elements.
And this is all stuff being
baked into the web platform
today by the browser vendors.
But we can use our compiler to
JavaScript to actually make
the future of web components
available today and deploy in
modern browsers today.
So it's really, really cool.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So talking about browsers and
maybe future browsers, when
can we expect something that
actually comes with a Dart VM?
Maybe performance that is
a great motivation.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
The VM is a great development
and debugging story.
Very quick iterations, but
there's also a performance
story there as well.
We use a system called
Snapshots, that have about of
10x performance increase for
start up time, because it
doesn't have to reparse
the source code.
It can start from the binary,
serialized snapshot.
But there's also a story
around just the raw
computation performance
of the Dart VM.
We're already beating
V8 on a bunch of
different benchmarks, and--
MALE SPEAKER: You know a
thing or two about V8.
It's the same people.
SETH LADD: Yeah, that's the
really cool thing, right?
If anybody knows speed, it's
these original developers that
did V8 and Hotspot and now
they're working on Dart.
I mean, that that's
a good sign.
But it's super early there, but
we have optimistic about
the performance getting
better.
And as far as actually landing
in browsers, we still have
work to do.
We have a build of Chromium
with a Dart VM in it.
So it all works today, but we
have more stability work to go
to prove to the Chrome guys
that his is something that
they want to put in.
And then as far as the other
browsers, I think the
important thing to remember is
Dart's success is really tied
to developer success.
So if developers using Dart
develop really awesome HTML5
modern apps and they're
compiling to JavaScript with
Dart, then that's a win.
If Dart just brings in more
developers to the Web
platform, that's good
for everybody.
MALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
performance.
Can you talk about maybe
adoption and where we are in
the road map and milestone
one [INAUDIBLE]?
Does it mean the language
is actually
stable completely now?
SETH LADD: It's pretty stable.
So about a year ago, we had a
technology preview, and we
listened to a lot of feedback.
We love the community
feedback.
And then we had the M1 launch,
which was our first public
beta of the SDK.
And the language is
fairly stable.
We don't anticipate any
backwards breaking changes
unless we run into
some massive bug.
We do anticipate new language
features as long as they don't
break backwards compatibility.
And then the future milestone
releases as we kind of march
towards a 1.0, we'll be working
on things like the
maturity of the platform, adding
in a couple of new
language features, better
performance, library
refactoring factoring.
So we're not at 1.0 yet, but the
M1 was a great milestone.
It's like, hey, developers,
you can now come check out
Dart, and we're not going to
rip up the language on you
underneath.
MALE SPEAKER: So we're
looking at six-week
cycles, releasing updates?
SETH LADD: I'm not exactly sure
what we've committed to,
but it does look like that
we're going to have a
Chromesque or Firefoxesque fast
iteration cycle and get
these new releases out
to developers.
We do push a new build every
week, which is really great.
But I think the milestones are
going to come pretty quickly,
which is nice.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great Any
final thoughts on what the
next year will look like and
what you want developers--
other try Dart, what kind of
feedback you're looking for?
SETH LADD: We're really looking
for feedback on web
components.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
a good time.
SETH LADD: Web components
is a big thing that
we're working on.
And again, this is going to
come down the web platform
anyway, but we're making this
available to developers.
Thanks for your compiling
to JavaScript.
And just keep working on
libraries that publish into
Pub or Package Manager.
I mean, this has helped
really everyone get
up and running by--
I mean, what's the best
productivity enhancement?
That is not to write code.
So if you can use other people's
code and use other
packages, it's fantastic.
So give those a shot.
Join us on the mailing list.
We're on Google+.
And we're an open source
project, and so you can jump
right into the issue tracker
and just file bugs.
It's all good.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Stack Overflow,
[? mailing list? ?]
SETH LADD: Stack Overflow
is really good.
Stack Overflow I'd probably
prefer, but numerous ways to
get ahold of this.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
where people are.
SETH LADD: We're very eager
to hear the feedback.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Well, I guess that's all the
time we have for it.
Thanks, Seth.
Good luck for the rest.
SETH LADD: Thank
you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.